und mein thema heute abend was nicht
bewegt ist der gender wahnsinn beim
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk ich sage
schluss mit der umerziehung also was ist
eigentlich passiert ich saß heute morgen
bei einem tee vor meinem handy wenn
durch instagram gestreut und kürzlich
habe ich gedacht was ist das ich habe
also angeschaut und zu sehen er wird sie
auch eingeblendet drei arten die freund
schauen dass sie durch die jenner ihnen
schaffen enden können ja das ist bei
mädels haben erschien das ist ein kanal
von funk und 5 ist es konnte ein
netzwerk von ard und zdf für junge
menschen wenn ich das hier freundinnen
schaffen dann habe ich mich erst mal
gefragt mein bester freunde die ich erst
ein mann ich bin eine frau soll ich
jetzt unsere freundschaft eine freundin
schafft nennen oder eine freundschaft
nennen damit keines von unserem
geschlechtern zu kurz kommt ich war wie
unsicher ich bleibe bei der freundschaft
aber spaß beiseite
das thema ist eigentlich viel größer als
ich darüber lustig zu machen weil das
pendant ist sexistisch ländern benötigt
nämlich eine sache die eigentlich gar
nicht mehr en vogue ist und zwar dass
man genau auf das geschlecht zeigt man
sagt du bist eine frau und du bist ein
mann in england zum beispiel gilt das
wort actress als sexistisch weil auch
das geschlecht verwiesen wird wenn ich
doch eigentlich in den beruf gehen soll
und deswegen sage ich schluss mit der
sendereihe schluss mit der freundinnen
schafft denn das ist sexistisch
coburg an wie sehen sie das sie sind
auch eine frau wenn wir jetzt befreundet
wären hätten wir eine freund innen
schafft oder dürfte ich noch
freundschaft sagen was würden sie
bevorzugen also tatsächlich finde ich
dieses thema so ein bisschen anstrengen
also ich man muss nicht irgendwie die
wörter so kommt komplizieren weil ich
wird tatsächlich bevorzugt wenn wir uns
einfach eine freundschaft nicht einfach
nennen als sie tatsächlich und ich finde
es beginnt auch schon diese ganze thema
allein schon bei der erziehung also ich
glaube wenn irgend wie die mütter haben
beziehungsweise eltern wirklich sich
darum kümmern würden was die kinder so
erzogen werden dass sie nicht dieser das
ist nicht so ausartet dass auch die
kinder so erzogen dass sie mehr darauf
achten auch dass die frau zum beispiel
mehr wie soll ich sagen dass ich mir das
mehr respekt auch über den herbst dann
würden wir glaube ich auch bei dem thema
gar nicht so so überlegen okay wie
könnte man das so ein bisschen
vorsichtiger angehen die themen und dem
begriff so umändern und sonstiges also
ich glaube das artet auch ein bisschen
außer durch gesagt herr templin man sagt
der sprache schärft das bewusstsein und
deswegen wäre das zu ändern wichtig ich
muss zwar sagen wenn ich in der schule
saß und man gesagt hat feueralarm
schüler alle raus bin ich nicht
sitzengeblieben habe gesagt ich bin aber
ein mädchen schüler witte aber man sagt
dass er trotzdem wie sehen sie das das
spricht für ihr sprachverständnis weil
viele begriffe wie schüler lehrer und so
weiter sprechen ja traditionell alle
möglichen geschlechter die ich habe ja
keine ahnung wie viele mittlerweile gibt
zu meiner zeit in meiner jugend gab es
glaube ich zwei das hat sich
mittlerweile ja geändert aber fakt ist
das ist auch eine frage wie man versucht
eben etwas
drüber zu setzen mit regelwerken über
also anderes thema nicht so ganz
emotional war ja damals auch die
rechtschreibreform die wurde bei den
sprach- lehrern auch emotional geführt
und jetzt ist das thema wie wird der
sprachfluss also
ich stelle es immer dann fest wenn also
dass jemand tatsächlich im alltag
spricht wir hatten das auch mal in einer
prüfungssituation darauf haben wir das
sehr beeindruckend dass das wirklich die
kandidatin die ganze zeit durchgehalten
die zu prüfende die ganze zeit
durchgehalten hat aber dann hat einer
stelle als dann der stress begann da
rutschte dann doch plötzlich wieder der
große fehler raus da merkt man das ist
gehirn akrobatik und ich will sagen das
soll jeder halten wie dachdecker für
sich entscheiden aber wenn man das
versucht tatsächlich so schulmeister
dich über zu werfen mit sprache das
kennen wir aus vorangegangenen deutschen
politischen systemen hat man schon immer
versucht die gesellschaft zu verändern
und gut gegangen ist eigentlich ein
kennen sie meine moderationsplan für
heute abend bei genau das sagte die
haller fort und das wollte ich einmal
einblenden jetzt dass es fast schon
vorweggenommen
versucht worden die sprache von oben
herab zu diktieren einmal verlieren da
sie ist und auch von den kommunisten das
hat nur unter druck funktioniert und
eben auch nur temporär so lange wieder
druck da war aber
ich werde jedenfalls diese scanner nicht
mitmachen weil ich dafür keine
notwendigkeit sehe um 72 prozent
das ändern ab da müssen wir doch als
sender darauf eingehen und wirst du
sagen okay die mehrheit bestimmter
demokratie und über das ist ein
plus wie sehen sie das lassen sie das
sondern auch sein oder wollen sie uns
damit anfangen damit die union jung und
cool wirken vielleicht sexy nein ich
lehne auch die gender sprache ab will
aber vielleicht noch mal eine sache
unterscheiden also wer privat so reden
möchte und sagen möchte zuschauer innen
oder zu hörende oder anwohner oder
fahrende oder freundinnen schafft der
soll das bei der grillparty tun ich
mache das nicht und ich kenne auch in
meinem freundeskreis niemanden der das
macht und glaube auch dass eine mehrheit
im land einfach normal deutsch spricht
aber der entscheidende punkt finde ich
ist doch dass diese gender sprache und
die ganze ideologie die dahinter steckt
immer stärker in öffentliche einrichtung
einzieht in universitäten in schulen die
schüler oder schülerinnen und schüler
lernen ja häufig gar nicht mehr richtig
die deutsche grammatik sondern kriegen
die gender sprache beigebracht die ja
grammatisch falsch ist und da finde ich
hörte der spaß dann auf das darf die
politik nicht zu lassen und deswegen
brauchen wir einen gender verbot in
schulen in universitäten in öffentlichen
einrichtungen da sollte die deutsche
grammatik beherrschen und die deutsche
grammatik gelebt werden ich mein man
kommt sich ja wirklich vor ein bisschen
wie ein absurdes daran dass man
überhaupt so etwas fordern muss und wer
das im privat anders halten will der
soll das tun aber
am ende und das dem programm vielleicht
auch noch mal machen wir sagen immer
auch völlig zurecht wenn wir über
integration sprechen
die sprache ist der schlüssel und
sprache so einfach und verständlich sein
wir haben ja nicht nur eine gender
sprache sondern es gibt ja die mit
doppelpunkt es gibt die mit gender
sternchen nicht es gibt die mit
irgendwie das alles in einem partizip
umgewandelt wird na also im zu hörende
oder studierende oder an wohnende oder
sparende oder mieten oder statt
sich seiner bauen also es wird da immer
abstruser und
das finde ich kann nicht sein da
brauchen wir auch wenn wir gerade im
schlafe ich sprache in öffentlichen
räumen reden in staatlichen
einrichtungen brauchen wir
verständlichkeit brauchen wir
einfachheit und brauchen wir die
deutsche grammatik zu unterstellen wir
uns gar keine frage zu berlin stellen
sonst müssen wir gleich die sendung
komplett
eine ganz kurze frage zu ihrer party und
dann kommt auch schon die these von
freiburg als sonst kommen wir nämlich
nicht mehr durch und zwar ist meine
frage ist es denn für menschen mit
migrationshintergrund vielleicht auch
dann schwieriger die deutsche sprache zu
erlernen durch das zu ändern
das kann ich gar nicht sagen für mich
war es bisher nicht schwierig ich kann
mir auch alle pronomen denke ich merken
wenn man das ernsthaft auch lernen
möchte ich denke eher sprache ist die
quelle der missverständnisse so steht es
ja auch im kleinen prinzen und dieses
phänomen haben wir hier gerade ich sehe
auch er das problem dass wenn es von
oben herab diktiert wird das ist dann
eher konträr zur redefreiheit steht das
habe ich aber ich würde es nicht
verbieten und wenn wir schon die
deutsche sprache lernen da kann man
vielleicht hier und da auch noch ein
pronomen lernt man niemandem auf den
schlips treten aber es sollte aber es
kann doch nicht sein dass ich noch nicht
ernsthaft sein das entscheiden die
lehrer teilweise nicht die deutsche
grammatik lehrern die können doch als
gender sprach aber die gender schwan
spricht nicht der deutschen grammatik
und ich finde die eltern und großeltern
in deutschland erwarten zu recht dass
die kinder die deutsche grammatik lernen
also man konnte ja wirklich vor wie in
absurdistan das teilweise schüler oder
schülerinnen und schüler sich dafür
einsetzen müssen dass sie in der schule
ein diktat in deutscher grammatik wird
na ja also wir sind viele alte
freunde die immer auch die grammatik gab
es zum thema